à cet endroit là nous avons les
fraisiers des framboisiers groseilliers
et même des cassissiers à 56 ans
bernadette déborde s'occupe du potager
biologique du domaine de madame
elisabeth à versailles agent immobilière
elle décide de se reconvertir dans
l'horticulture
après une formation au chef elle signe
un contrat aidé en janvier 2017 avec le
conseil départemental
je vois vraiment pas comment on pourrait
comment dire arrêter une disposition
comme celle là parce qu'elle a quand
même contribué à ramener sur le marché
du travail
beaucoup de personnes que l'on croyait
perdus entre 2016 et 2017 plus de 700
contrats aidés ont été signés par le
département plusieurs postes dans les
collèges au service espaces verts ou
dans les services administratifs ce type
de contrat c'est 20 heures de travail 6
heures de formation un dispositif devant
permettre aux bénéficiaires du rsa un
retour à l'emploi
l'intérêt c'est aussi de les former et
d'abord une formation qualifiante et si
possible une formation diplômante ci
fait qu'à la fin de son contrat avec
l'accompagnement qui activity pouvait
faire ça permettait à ces gens là de
retrouver soit un emploi soit de
retrouver une formation peut être plus
performant qui correspond à leur vrai
projet professionnel pour un contrat
aidé la charge financière mensuelle du
département s'élève à 490 euros pour
l'état elles représentent entre 300 et
400 euros par mois le gouvernement
voulant supprimer ce dispositif les
collectivités devraient compenser la
participation budgétaire de l'état
ensuite dire que ça coûte cher oui
incontestablement
mais ça ne pourra pas être porté par les
collectivités si parallèlement on
continue à retirer de l'argent en
collectivité
en 2016 les yvelines estime avoir
enregistré une baisse de 9 % des
bénéficiaires du rsa
grâce aux contrats aidés